to my flat as you see it's it still
doesn't have even a door Alexa more
Resolve is looking to the Future one
where a treasured past in this apartment
will be rebuilt of course it was not a
flat it was a big hole here yeah and
with with lots of dust and lots of
glasses around around
[Music]
on the third day of the war these images
were seen around the world a shocking
demonstration that civilians in
Ukraine's Capital were in the firing
line
Alexi and his family had moved to a
nearby bomb shelter only hours earlier
it's more strange it's more amazing that
my children
asked me
sorry
my boy he's nine years old
and he doesn't understand what does this
word means
[Music]
Alexi and his wife Maria lived here with
their daughter and two sons it was their
youngest boy mikola who came to them the
night before the strike he went to our
bedroom here and asked us
uh parents please
let's go to shelter because the
television tells us that it's a safe
place and we have to move
and then we move
it's extraordinary I mean how do you
reflect on that now I mean that's now I
understand that the God exists
the floor peeled away and hanging in the
void was the one that supported his
son's bunk bed so if my if my boys would
sleep in this room this night
I'm sure evening
yeah
he and his fellow residents raised tens
of thousands of dollars in the days
after the strike to buy supports to keep
the building intact now the key of city
government is funding the Reconstruction
of all the affected floors what happened
here back in February was a stark symbol
of the sheer scale of the war that was
coming to Ukraine the efforts to rebuild
here are of course pragmatic and
required for those who used to live here
but they're also symbolic for a country
that wants to demonstrate resilience
can you still visualize it in your in
your mind of course I remember how it it
looked for Alexi there are no doubts
about returning here he wants to put his
old apartment his family's life back
together as it was
if
our Angel was so strong to prevent us
from the this rocket we do not scare in
nothing we was carrying nothing here
this war may be grinding on into the
winter but for Alexi and his family an
important personal Victory is in sight
Harry Fawcett Al Jazeera Kiev